good evening councilors officers and
members of the press and public and
anyone else who I may have missed out I
welcome to this first full meeting of
the council since the annual Council of
the 16th of May it is the opportunity
for new counselors to experience
procedure and for former councilors to
refresh their skills first some
important announcements if the fire
alarm is activated please vacate the
offices via the stairs either through
the security doors to my right or
opposite the lifts in the foyer to the
rear of the chamber please do not use
the lifts please assemble in Hawley
square on the open green officers will
assist you and advise when it is in safe
to return to the chamber with respect to
webcasting of proceedings the
Proceedings of this meeting tonight will
be recorded and subsequently broadcast
on the Internet I would advise that if
filming takes place anyone in attendance
in the public areas may have their image
captured I urge anyone filming
proceedings to avoid filming members of
the public particularly if there are
children present
does anyone intend to film the meeting
any member of the public who objects the
possibility of being filmed may wish to
take this opportunity to leave the
meeting and I take it everyone therefore
is happy since no one is moving any
filming or recording will not be
permitted for any item of business we're
exempt or confidential information is
considered following the exclusion of
the press and public from the meeting
with respect to restriction of the use
of mobile phones would everyone present
please ensure that their mobile phones
are timed to silent and that they are
not used to make or receive phone calls
in a chamber while this meeting is in
progress thank you very much
now moving on to agenda item 1 apologies
for absence I believe we have two
apologies
they are we have Paula G's from
councillor Boyd and council attorney
anybody else councillor Piper Thank You
chairman councilor 30 Braidwood
and could I just ask counsel to note the
untimely death of his father the funeral
was today
and I'd like to be able to assure him of
the very best wishes of all of his
colleagues here in this place thank you
thank you very much for that councillor
Piper and I'm sure every councillor
officer and member of the public here
feels the same way and extends their
concern condolences moving on to agenda
item 2 the minutes of the previous
meeting held on the 16th of May 2019 I
move that the minutes of the meeting of
this council held on the 16th of May
2018 be approved and signed as a correct
record with the vice chairman please
second at second to chairman Thank You
members agree thank you agenda item 3 I
have an announcement this evening which
honors our past chairman the
presentation of the past Chairman's
badge no less would councillor David
Saunders please make his way to the top
table please would counselors be up
standing while I present the past
chairman with his badge
carry on Stanley if you like can I just
say that I'd like to thank all of the
counselors that were here when I was
elected to the position of chairman and
for their support over the previous year
it was really enjoyable going out once
again to represent Thanet in the wider
areas of Kent and I'll particularly like
to thank the support that I received
from Charlie and John the drivers during
that time so thank you very much I will
wear this badge with pride whenever
possible thank you thank you very much
indeed councillor Saunders he's going to
be a hard up to follow I can assure you
moving on to agenda item four five sorry
petitions no pardon my apology agenda
item four declarations of interests are
there any declarations of interest here
this evening
Catholic aim Thank You chairman a
question five I'm actually on the board
of East Kent housing I can't take that
question the leader will take it instead
thank you thank you very much councilor
game any other declarations of interest
this evening and I don't see any moving
on to agenda item five petitions a
petition has been received in accordance
with council procedure rule number 12
agenda item 5 a petition regarding
margot Clocktower toilets a competition
containing 386 valid signatures has been
received by this council council yes you
have up to three minutes to introduce
your petition Thank You chair one of the
reasons I became a counselor is because
I got annoyed with the states of the TS
Eliot toilets and looking down on them
from my flat and
enclosed on busy bank holiday weekends
and it's not the frustration that
they're closed because leaks happened
problems happen but it's the fact that
there's no temporary portaloos being put
in for the record have no interest in
ports new companies so why was this
specific petition raised on the 18th of
April 20 19 t VC issued a press release
press release Rou said Margit Clocktower
toilets will remain closed this
temporary closure that clock tower
toilets is results of pre-season
inspection in which they are found to be
unsafe where we're looking at putting
temporary to--let's in places summer
whilst the Clocktower silla tees are
closed her petitioners there for raises
is becoming increasingly clear that the
toilets and structural issues and no
chumpy to--let's were being put in place
to my knowledge the only temporary
toilets that have been put in place this
summer have been for Margate meltdown on
the last weekend of May which is partly
because the Weatherspoon's was closed to
refurbishment so the short-term question
therefore comes down to why they no
Tempe to--let's in place and this is
causing huge queues of the TS Eliot
toilets and this is disproportionately
affecting women so onto the issue of
cost
I've spoken to council offices and there
are savings that have been made because
of the closure the Clocktower toilets
due to the lack of water bills the
weekly rental cost of a portaloo on
Margate seafront is 29 pounds a week
with a small on cost on top for cleaning
with the Turner Prize coming to Margate
I really hope that the council will take
notice to the level of passion behind
this issue and use some of the cost
savings to put Tempe toilets in place
and give their heart harbor arm toilets
some door locks potentially the petition
has been signed by nearly 400 people so
I think it's worthwhile just to hear
quickly from the local residents of
businesses so I've got that quotes this
is from a pub owner as a local
businessman suffering from the closure
of the Clocktower toilets I have to ask
to the council care of our local
businesses being dirty mentally affected
not only as a businessman but also as a
local enjoys our beautiful beach and my
family I would like to know what
solutions the council plans to offer to
a place as basic immunity the closure
the toilets have a huge negative effect
on the local area
and it is such a shame when locals have
worked so hard to regenerate local area
and boost tourism
one resident commented on the
alternative toilets saying the toilets
on the harbour are an absolute disgrace
they are seriously hurting the
businesses here and the events organized
of the toilet protest on the 25th of
April outside this building has said
there is a level of fury and outrage
among residents in response to the
councilors constant fobbing off with
cheap words and inaction the council
would do well to take the note of a
movement and started and we the
residents of Thanet will be holding TDC
to account finally where the term prize
coming to Margate and the public outrage
from visitors businesses and locals we
hope the council will take notice and
repair the Clocktower toilets put Templi
toilets in place to replace them at busy
times and perhaps improve the nearby
toilets for example by putting door
locks on the toilet cubicles at the
harbour arm thank you thank you very
much councillor Yates in accordance with
the council's petition scheme the
petition will be referred to cabinet
without debate for report to the council
within three ordinary meetings
moving on to agenda item six questions
from the press and public four questions
have been received from members of the
public in accordance with the council
procedure rule number 13 please note
that only the questioner and respondent
are permitted to speak on the question
and as if the question is not present at
the meeting their question cannot be put
but will be replied to in writing could
the questioner please only state the
name of the cabinet member to whom their
question is to be put and read out the
exact wording of the question that they
submitted to the council would members
now please refer to supplementary agenda
number one that you should all have had
so moving straight on to agenda item 6a
question number one from a member of the
public regarding noise nuisance and
please welcome mr. Schewel to the
meeting could you please make your way
to the top table
yes could you come down on my left-hand
side please thank you
Leslee game statutory noise nuisance
policy and practice requires urgent
strategic operational overhaul rendering
it fit for purpose to deal with ASB
we're residential streets disturbances
involve car stereo karaoke mobile phones
function functioning as street based
sound systems can annoys abatement
officer lee aging out of hours with an
ax police be instituted thank you very
much indeed for that mr. Schewel i'm
sure we're sympathetic with that I call
upon council game to respond statutory
noise nuisance is defined by the
Environmental Protection Act 1990 and
changes to that are outside of the remit
of the local authority sanik District
Council has agreed an environmental
enforcement policy which follows the
principles of the National enforcement
concordia to assist environmental
protection officers in undertaking
proportionate enforcement this is
currently being reviewed to ensure that
it is still appropriate and your
concerns can be fed into this review it
should be noted that a statutory
nuisance is very different different to
disturbance
unfortunately resources are all public
services are not sufficient enough to
provide the tow type of service you are
suggesting but we do provide an out of
our service to gather evidence in
ongoing cases and work closely with Kent
Police on relevant cases the
Environmental Protection Team
investigate over 1,000 noise complaints
a year a majority of which are from
domestic premises which reported to us
music in the street is investigated
thank you thank you very much councilor
game
moving on to agenda item 6b question
number 2 from a member of the public
regarding hedgerow and tree meant
maintenance I'm pleased to welcome miss
Matt we to the meeting could you please
make your way to the top table thank you
thank you I'm addressing my question to
Ashe Ashe Ashe be I'm a member of the
local environmental group Thanet trees
will TDC create paper trails as to who
orders works on trees and hedgerows so
that someone is accountable for any
felling and trimming and are they
willing to reinstate the full-time tree
officer thank you very much miss pathway
I call upon councillor Ashby to respond
thank you thank you for your question
I'd like to advise that following the
recent review the additional processes
for works on trees and hedgerows will be
Emelia dotted by the open space team
this includes an ecological risk
assessment to be carried out for a
variety of parks and open space works
this improved process will include the
use of new technology to include a
thermal imaging wildlife camera recently
purchased and currently being trialed
this will be used alongside the
traditional methods of ecological
monitoring as part of the prescribed
process that must be followed before
works are carried out check sheets will
be included as part of the ecological
risk assessment to ensure compliance is
documented
recommendations are also being sought
from the RSPB Wildlife Trusts and other
local authorities to help develop this I
can also confirm that fanuc District
Council will be recruiting arborist for
the district
thank you very much councillor Ashby
I move on to agenda item 6c question
number three from a member of the public
regarding an environment and
biodiversity strategy I call upon mr.
wises to make his way to the top table
thank you
thank you
questions to councillor Beauford given
the growing public interest and concern
with regard to our natural environment
will the council commit to preparing an
environment and biodiversity strategy
and associated policies for Thanet
publish a timeline for completion and
include consultation with local experts
and other interested parties in the work
program thank you very much mr. wise I
call upon the leader to respond thank
you
hm Thank You mr. Weiss your question
it's important that we move towards a
sustainable future where Thanet is
resilient to an environmental change
must also address the risks impacts and
opportunities arising from that change
later this evening I'm anticipating the
council will agree to a number of
actions in connection with declaring a
climate emergency and I'm sure that the
creation of an environment and
biodiversity strategy can be considered
by cabinet along with any other
proposals being recommended it should be
noted that there is currently a Kent
biodiversity strategy in place being
overseen by the nature partnership as
well as KCC's own can environment
strategy it would obviously make sense
to see how these documents and the
activities associated with them might
inform our own strategy this will also
afford avoid any duplication of efforts
thank you
well there you have it
Thank You councillor Beauford agenda
item 6d a question number 4 from a
member of the public regarding Margate
Clocktower toilets I'm pleased to
welcome miss Eleanor to the meeting
could you please make your way to the
top table thank you
I have my question is for councillor
Ashe Ashe be with the high season
student that's approaching when will
that District Council fix and reopen the
Clocktower toilets to accommodate the
vast amount of visitors to the town
thank you very much miss Alana I call
upon councillor Ashby to respond these
now fall within a more strategic
approach to the whole provision of
toilet facilities across the district it
would therefore not be cost effective to
spend several thousand pounds on this
facility until we agree the investment
strategy going forward there are several
other toilets within close proximity
that people can use in terms of events
organisers should be providing
additional toilets if this is deemed a
requirement by our safety advisory board
thank you very much councillor Ashby
thank you Miss Alana moving on to agenda
item 7 I have questions from members of
this council now seven questions have
been received from members of the
council please note that the time
allowed for consideration of the
questions from members should not exceed
30 minutes without leave off the chair
on this occasion there for 30 minutes
limit is exceeded as chairman I will
allow the remaining questions to be
heard if I have to ask members to be
succinct as far as possible
as the council does have a full agenda
this evening so moving straight on to
agenda item 7a question number 1 from a
member regarding traveler incursions I
call upon councillor Taylor even sure
I'll direct my question at count 2 again
the question is how is the new
administration going to tackle the
expensive traveler incursions thank you
very much council tailor I call upon
councillor game to respond thank you
and thank you can't say tailor for your
question a significant amount of
activity is underway to address the
growing number of unauthorized
encampments across the district which in
2018 rose to 55 the council is
developing a strategy to ensure its
resources are targeted as effectively as
possible and this work is being
coordinated by a new officer task and
finish group the group which was
established in February has been
focusing on the following key areas of
work developing and implementing an
action plan for the potential of
traveler accommodation defining and
improving the security of high-risk
locations defining and undertaking
enforcement to protect high-risk
locations robustly challenging criminal
and antisocial behaviors positive
progress is being made and this work
will now feed into the newly created
traveler scrutiny working group which
held its inaugural meeting today updates
will provide provided to all councillors
on this work as it progresses thank you
thank you very much councilor game Casa
Taylor do you have a supplementary
question that'd be fine sir thank you
very much well moving on to agenda item
7b question number two from a member
regarding child poverty
I call upon councillor Constantine thank
you very much chair I believe that I've
got two minutes to put my question I'm
going to use two minutes and I'd like to
start my outlining the effects of child
poverty in the area
we know that children suffering from
child poverty have poor physical health
experience mental health problems have a
low sense of well-being experience
social deprivation feel unsafe
experience stigma and bullying at school
children from poorer backgrounds lag to
all stages of education by the age of
three poorer children are estimated to
be on average nine months behind
children from more wealthy backgrounds
by 16 children receiving free school
meals achieve 1.7 grades lower
GCSE poverty is also associated with
higher risk of both illness and
premature oDesk death children from
low-income families are more likely to
die at birth or in infancy they are more
likely to suffer chronic illness during
child childhood or have a disability
recent recent research shows a nice has
the highest rate of child poverty in
Kent in wealthy Kent with Newington now
one of the most severely affective
Ward's with child poverty are too
shocking 51 percent of children in that
Ward Cliftonville West Des Valley 46
percent northward Margate Central and
psalmist earn 42 percent that's 35
percent of children in sanik living
below the poverty line that's eleven
thousand four hundred and seventy four
of our sanity youngsters been raised in
poverty what I would like to know from
the chair our thinking is from the
council leader is this is my question
child poverty is unchecked and growing
in parts of Kent in my ward Newington
recent research shows 51 percent of all
children living in poverty
can you explain what targets TDC is put
into place to mitigate the impact of
this poverty thank you very much indeed
Couser Couser
I would remind you of course that
normally speaking the strict wording of
the question should be presented at
council meeting to ensure proper
response is given I call upon the leader
councilor Beauford thanks Sherman thank
you caster constant sign for your
question and you're absolutely right and
child poverty is a real issue but it's
not something that the council can
tackle alone and to defeat it will
require a wholesale change in the
district through education job
opportunities general economic growth
and the supply of good housing some of
the main root causes of child poverty or
unemployment low earnings and education
all of which sit outside the statutory
powers of a district council therefore
the council does not have specific
targets set to mitigate the impact of
child poverty
having said that the council does have a
hit shared responsibility with other
public sector agencies in mitigating the
impacts of child poverty strategically
the council will use its position as
leader of place to influence partners
for instance in job creation and
economic growth currently there are a
range of interventions funded and
delivered by the council to support
residents during the summer holidays the
council will be running the fit and feed
project in you intern and Broadstairs
which provides sport and healthy eating
sessions for families who rely on free
school meals during term time the
council fund step up which is an
employability skills training program
for council tenants to assist them with
CV writing job applications and job
search the counts will give
discretionary housing payments to people
receiving housing benefit or the housing
cost element of Universal Credit who
need more help with their housing needs
this year the council has increased the
funding to support Citizens Advice
bureaux who provide debt advice and
money capability services to all
residents to reduce financial burdens in
poorer households the council has
committed to a three-year funding
arrangements which does include key
performance indicators the council has
taken the decision to limits of its
affordable rents for the local housing
allowance rate which is less than the
government 2011 policy on affordable
rent which states no more than 80% of
market rent the majority of the
councillors homes are lesser historical
social rents which should be more
affordable to lower-income households
social rent calculates the target rent
for each property based on a combination
of individual property values and
average earnings in each area the
private sector rented team focuses on
improving standards in rented
accommodation they work with landlords
and tenants to ensure that the legal
standards for housing a met the local
plan has a target of 30% affordable
housing we are working with Save the
Children on the eat sleep learn and play
project which aims to alleviate the
immediate material needs of families
living in poverty
improving their young person's
well-being helping them to learn and
develop an items that the project have
delivered include household items like
cookers washing
jeans mattresses and bedding and also
things help children like children's
bedroom sets so my book bundles and bunk
beds high chairs and push chairs thank
you thank you very much councillor David
kassick constant I've more than a notion
that you may have a supplementary
question the scale of the problem is
fast isn't it it's 35 percent of our
children are living in poverty and last
week action for children said the UK is
sleepwalking into a crisis of childhood
with youngster struggling to cope with
anxieties over issues such as bracelet
poverty and climate crisis I understand
italic District Council doesn't have a
magic wand or a money tree to deal with
this situation I understand that we need
to work with partner organizations but I
also understand from working within the
voluntary sector within within residents
that a lot of the solutions that you've
just outlined actually don't work for
people and leave these children
remaining in poverty so what I would
really like to to cancer constant I can
have the question please I'm coming to
the question I always get interrupted I
take it to heart you know and what I
would like to suggest is that we form a
working party with experts to set some
targets to start to look at how we can
properly deal with this catastrophe
question please come to constant time
were Sebastian that was my question it
didn't quite like sound like one kept me
at the leader
would you like to respond to a question
we're presuming on I think it's a
typical caster constituent question
which sounds much more like a party
political statement than a question but
but Europe yeah I do absolutely agree a
child poverty is unacceptable it surely
is but as I said in in my response to
your question now this council doesn't
actually hold the levers so setting
targets is difficult so I was a working
parties concerned I'm very happy to meet
you outside of this chamber to talk
about what a working party might
actually do ask to have sense of all
terms of reference it has
be capable of delivering something so if
you're happy to accept that caster
constant I'll look forward to sitting
down with you thank you well there you
have it Thank You councillor BAE effort
agenda item 7c question number three
from a member
regarding the restoration of sites in
cliftonville although members please
refer to supplementary agenda number one
for the remaining questions from members
in this instance I call upon councillor
curry thank you Thank You chair the
Newgate gap shelter the Oval Bandstand
the forum Butlins and minigolf sites are
among many derelict sites or rundown
areas of Cliftonville West that require
restoration or development this is one
of the most deprived Ward's in Kent what
is the council doing to facilitate this
process and thank you very much
councillor curry
I call upon councillor Saunders to
respond Thank You chairman and Thank You
councillor curry for your question which
I'll answer in four parts if I may with
regards to the new get shelter with the
Ruth in a state of disrepair and on the
grounds of health and safety perimeter
harris fencing was recently installed as
we all know around the structure and I
would confirm that in conjunction with
operations services the remaining
roofing is being removed once this
exercise is completed the counts will
then be able to progress the community
asset transfer process and will be
contacting the community groups to
discuss and progress the matter further
the oval bandstand is already on the
disposal list and plans are in place to
transfer the bandstand under the
community asset transfer policy to a
local group regarding the mini golf site
this was available to let but
regretfully we had no suitable
applications were received
officers are therefore investigating
alternative uses including the
possibility of transforming the site
into a community garden or similar
but it is proving difficult to get the
required funding but we're still
investigating that possibility can I
therefore add that the council would
welcome any alternative suggestions to
improve the environment from ward
councillors and the community of Clifton
work Ville West in general
finally the former Batlin site is
privately owned and therefore not a
council matter that said we will be
keeping a watchful eye on any future
planning proposal submitted for outside
thinking thank you very much indeed
councillor Saunders Gaza kuri do you
have a supplementary at all I do yeah
thank you for that councillor Saunders
will the council commit to publishing a
regular quarterly update to members on
progress so these matters are kept in
the public eye thank you Thank You
councillor courier caught up on
councillor Saunders as you probably know
we have a number of assets on the
disposal list and I'm quite happy that
once these progress through once we got
through the legal saga of transferring
them that members are informed
immediately
thank you very much councillor Saunders
agenda item 70 question number four from
a member regarding the appointment of a
tree officer
I call upon councillor Duckworth and you
said you will be appointing a tree
officer within the council but can you
confirm that the one will who is
appointed whether that position will be
a council position or durn on a contract
basis considering the necessity of the
role and a solid employment within our
area
thank you very much councillor Duckworth
I pull upon councillor Ashby to respond
I've stated before and I'm pleased to
reconfirm that we will be advertising
and recruiting a person for the post of
an arborist and we will who will be in
position as soon as a suitable candidate
is found
I can also confirm that the position
will be within and employed by Anik
District Council
thank you very much councillor Ashby
that's positive news councillor
Duckworth do you have a supplementary
question I'm considering again the
necessity of inherent secure employment
which makes oversight of contracts and
where it strains much simpler in
relation to third party contract that
resulting in significant damages to
hedges at the winter garden site what
specific measures are being put into
place to either bring these services
in-house or ensure adequate oversight
and monitoring of these contracts and
the works undertaken thank you very much
councillor Duckworth I call upon
councillor Ashby thank you as I stated
in the previous answer and everything is
being put in place then re-examined and
check sheets will be included as part of
the risk assessment process for both
in-house and external contractors to
make sure they're complying with all the
regulations that are concerned with any
projects of this nature so thank you
thank you very much cancer Ashby that
you can't come back on that councillor
Duckworth that's as far as it goes I'm
afraid this evening you'll sell well of
course that's always nice thanks very
much indeed
there we are that's good thank you very
much moving on to agenda item 7e a
question number five from a memory
guarding East Kent housing I call upon
councillor whitehead good evening
everyone
I believe I'm directing this to you
counselor no counselor game I think it
would be to the leader tonight okay
white and right
good evening councillor David
considering the failures in relation to
the East Kent housing contract can you
tell me what measures are underway to
ideally bring our housing back into
Intel's management and in the interim to
protect tenants who have been failed in
terms of Health and Safety under care
thank you very much councillor whitehead
I called upon the leader council of
Bedford
thanks Gemma
thank you for your question and the
council was alerted to the situation
regarding the failure of the gas supply
contract during May 2019 by which time
up to 130 TDC properties did not have a
valid landlord gas safety report and LGS
are some had been outstanding for more
than two months the situation is similar
to the other East Kent councils I'm
pleased to update that the current
position has improved and as at the 9th
of July there were 13 outstanding all of
which either have booked appointments or
in the legal process for access recovery
measures were put in place involving
several default these serving default
notices on the contractor and issuing
works to a selected list of alternative
contractors akh have big dedicated staff
to contacting residents and arranging
appointments LGS ours are a statutory
health and safety requirement and this
level of outstanding properties
represents a significant risk to the
council and to residents the councillors
top priority regarding this matter is
the safety of our tenants EK HR
providing regular updates on progress
new LG SRS fall due each week and it is
essential that EK h provide continual
robust management of this to ensure that
the situation continues to improve and
does not deteriorate the Health and
Safety Executive are aware of the
position and the recovery arrangements
landlords are also required to report
any significant breaches of required
standards to the regulator for social
housing and CDC has written to the
regulator to inform them of the position
the council's monitoring officer will be
required to report the situation to
members formally and the paper has been
drafted for the July meeting of cabinet
the report will be accompanied by a
further report sitting out the
circumstances of recovery actions and
future intervention options both of
these reports have been circulated to
all members and will be published from
the councils website on the 15th of July
the further report sets out a range of
alternative arrangements for the future
management that the counselors housing
stock which will be considered by
cabinet on the 25th of July the report
further advises about the issues that
will need to be considered in detail
before a decision about the future can
be taken and about the need for
extensive resident consultation if any
fundamental changes in the arrangements
are proposed in the meantime I've
authorized the chief executive to take
whatever interim action is required to
safeguard the safety of tenants which I
would emphasize again is our top
priority the four counts of chief
executives are meeting at least weekly
with the chief executive of e KH about
this matter and have met with the chair
of e KH board and will be meeting with
the full board shortly these meetings
will continue to ensure that the focus
of improving health and safety
arrangements is maintained and to
identify any further interventions
required this is being backed up with
work being completed by the east can
audit partnership and supplementary
inspections by TD officers of council
and blocks with the authority to issue
works orders directly if required I
speak for the whole of cabinet in
committing to ensure that the recently
highlighted issues with tenant Health
and Safety are urgently resolved and
that the council considers all of the
available options to secure the best
possible future management arrangement
for tenants thank you very much
councillor Beauford that seemed very
thorough but councillor whitehead I
sense you're on the edge of your seat so
I guess there's a supplementary
following I'm afraid there were likely
always thank you very much for that
councillor David I believe it's our duty
as a chamber and our duty of the council
to look out for our most vulnerable
residents and in relation to our council
housing it hasn't been happening as
evidenced by these kind of housing issue
and if we think about a lot of our most
vulnerable residents they are being
chased out of area they are often being
placed I'm currently working with a very
vulnerable tenant
No and we need to make sure that
vulnerable tenants Oh counsel white hey
could I have a question please my
question is can we make sure that in
terms of the placements of particularly
vulnerable people thinking in relation
to my work with the Winter Shelter
can we make sure that we are
continuously and effectively monitoring
through robust consultation that the
effect of particular housing placements
on residents yes counselor whitehead I'm
not quite sure we fully understood the
question leader would you like to
respond as you see fit to that sort of
statement sort of question responders us
they say no I mean quite frankly I mean
you've raised the totally different
issue to the one of East Kent housing
and that was what we're addressing
tonight but I think your concerns are
noted and I'm sure that counts the game
when I no longer has to substitute for
it will actually handle that much better
than I could thank you thank you very
much indeed councillor Beauford I just
should mention that it does help people
answering questions if a proper question
and I'm not saying that in any intention
otherwise but an a readily
understandable question would enable an
easy reply just for future reference and
for future councils thank you very much
indeed
I have quest a gender item 7f question
number six from a member regarding
Community Safety
I call upon councillor Roth Thank You
chair my question is easy-peasy
considering that you have recently had a
high profile racially motivated incident
can you tell me what measure are in
place to guarantee that we are ensuring
that sanity is a safe and welcoming
place for all visitors and resident
thank you thank you very much castle
Roth I call upon councillor came to
respond
Thank You chair and Thank You councillor
ruff for your question
whilst we are actually unable to comment
on an ongoing police investigation I can
reassure you that the council are
committed to providing a safe and
welcoming environment for visitors and
residents we work with other statutory
agencies in the Sanok Community Safety
Partnership and with the local community
through our regular neighborhood
engagement meetings the police community
liaison officer who specializes in
incidents of this type works within the
co-located team in the council office
which enables us to be fully engaged
when providing support every incident of
hate crime is discussed at the police
threat risk and harm meeting and contact
made on every occasion victim and
perpetrator information is discussed and
action plans developed as applicable
thank you thank you very much indeed
councillor came to I have first
supplementary councillor Wolfe thank you
considering the importance of
established community based in the West
in promoting community will the council
commit to looking at existing anti
racism project to see how they could be
involved in supporting the council
commitment to promote and commitment to
promote and cohesion and equality Thank
You councillor ruff
councillor game do you have a response
to that thank you as I said earlier we
are absolutely committed providing a
safe and welcoming environment for our
visitors and residents
absolutey if you'd like to meet with me
and discuss this and discuss your
thoughts in greater depth and I'm happy
to do so thank you Thank You council
again that's very accommodating I have
another question agenda item 7g question
number 7 from a member regarding member
training I call upon councillor
Hopkinson
this questions for councillor recipe
question is as councillors where should
I stand sorry as councillors we're
likely to encounter residents requiring
mental health assistance
sometimes urgently as part of our
casework so with the council therefore
consider providing first aid mental
health training to help members
recognize mental health warning signs
and to direct residents towards
appropriate help Thank You councillor
pew sorry okay councillor Hopkinson
Kastrup you do you have a response to
that question thank you chairman and
thank you council Hopkinson for your
questions councillors can and do request
training on a wide variety of topics and
this council has provided many courses
for both new members as part of the
recent induction programme and during
the last council term i'm sure that you
will be familiar with the learning needs
analysis that has recently been
circulated to all councillors by our
democratic services team this document
helps councillors to identify gaps in
their knowledge and has used my
democratic services to build the member
training program for the rest of this
musical municipal year I would urge you
and indeed all councillors to complete
this document and to include your
suggestion and it will be considered for
inclusion when the results of the
learning needs analysis and the draft
remember training programme are
considered by the member training group
Thank You councillor pew casual
Hopkinson do you have a supplementary to
that yeah thank you for that well
suppose I wonder if I could ask you yes
counselor pew at Hopkins could you
please stand alright thank you
personal view on this issue given what
seems to be to me to be an increasing
need to you know cater for mental health
issues which seem to be on the increase
Infinite's I wonder what your personal
view is on that on the specific issue as
well as the comments you made about the
fact that you're open to hearing from
the rest of us more about it but I
wonder what your your personal view is
on that on this issue on the need for
this training those Thank You councillor
Hopkinson counsel appeared youth have
anything to add to that I do thank you
chairman
Thank You council optin I mean I think
it's evident be clear to all councillors
new and old that we experience and many
residents come to us with a variety of
issues and difficulties that they're
having personally for themselves and
with issues with the council and the
district as a whole I think it's
probably best that we meet privately to
discuss this and I'd be more than happy
to do so the member training group was
due to meet this morning to kick starts
the next kind of stage of looking at new
training programs and unfortunately mr.
Nick Hughes was unwell so it was
cancelled but I look forward to it being
rescheduled soon so that we can really
start looking into this properly
thank you very much council appear that
is the end of the questions we have this
evening from councillors moving on to
agenda item 8 motions on a notice two
motions on notice have been received in
accordance with council procedure rule 3
moving straightly on to agenda item 8a
therefore a motion on notice in relation
to the declaration of a climate change
emergency
I call upon councillor Yates for the
wording of his motion Thank You Jay
according to the IPCC we are less than
12 years away from catastrophic climate
change in this time we as a planet must
achieve reduction of our co2 emissions
by 50% or tipping point is reached in
humans and intervention to prevent with
unstoppable global warming becomes much
much more difficult nearly every single
major national scientific body around
the world unreservedly supports the
works and findings of the IPCC so I hope
this science tonight is not up for
debate it is with this in mind that we
propose to declare a climate emergency
in the hope that we are standard just a
council can play our parts names to be
carbon neutral by 2030 so what can be
done locally when it comes to buildings
we can ask for new bills to be zero
carbon we can support the vulnerable by
ensuring the properties are insulated as
part of legal ECA obligations we can
assess energy efficiency measures and
planning applications when it comes to
waste we can increase the number of
flats to recycle as they're currently
16,000 flats we know recycle bins at all
we can add additional recycling bins or
recycling points when it comes to energy
we can offer a green electricity
supplier for council property and we can
support applications for new able energy
schemes when it comes to transport we
can promote greener refuse vehicles
promote no idling areas outside of
schools and work with KCC to improve the
Viking trail and cycle lanes and also
established 20 new mile-an-hour zones
where necessary when it comes to trees
and green spaces we can ensure that TDC
tree officer and KCC work to plant more
trees and wildflowers encouraging a bee
corridor use safer neighborhood grants
to improve parks and work with local
groups to help compost any waste
material left by the council and there
are many other easy wins the TDC pension
for example pays into a pension fund
this sits on fossil fuel investments
worth over 267 million pounds
I'm not a financial adviser I would
hazard guest investing money in fossil
fuel companies is not a great long-term
investment divesting this money away
from fossil fuels might be a win-win
situation for pension holders as well as
the planet so what does this motion say
this motion ask the council's pledged
that is within the council powers to
make TDC carbon neutral by 2030 we call
on Westminster for support to reach his
target and work with partners across the
county in region to support this and
investigate future funding opportunities
it is not possible to include within
this motion any requirement for the
council to produce an action report
within six months but following on
dialogue from the leader of the council
we would appreciate if the leader could
commit to producing a national report
within six months and present this to
Council
for those wondering about this motion
this is not the new motion a climate
emergency has already been declared and
five councils in the southeast and is in
progress in 13 other councils in the
southeast this movement is growing one
point from labour and Green Party
locally we are aware the KCC has pushed
back the timeline for similar motion to
2050 so if there are any amendments that
aim to weaken this both labour and green
parties and we hope other parties here
will aim to vote against any amendment
an emergency becomes significantly less
urgent when it's pushed back 20 years
dear council members council staff and
members of the public the time for
talking on climate action is over and
the time for action is now
I honestly a scanner shoots move on to
the actual wording of your motion please
job don't say if it lost the most
important bit
I was I was reaching a very good ending
so the council resolves to declare a
climate emergency it's a pledge to do
what is within our powers and resources
to make fun it is a council carbon
neutral by 2030 taking into account both
production and consumption emissions
call on Westminster to provide the
powers and resources to make the 2030
target possible continue to work with
partners across the cancer County in
region to deliver this new goal through
all relevant strategies request the
council investigate all possible sources
of external funding and match funding to
support this commitment thank you thank
you very much councillor Yates of course
this is a matter close to all our hearts
I'm sure every councillor in this
chamber is sympathetic to this concern
and it's good to have such a lively and
proactive public gallery thank you very
much for attending this evening
everybody
I presume you have a seconder for this
motion can L second thank you hello who
seconded
thank you very much
I call upon the leader counselor
Beaufort to respond thank you yes thank
chairman it's very simple you had
conversations with both the counselors
that are proposing this second in this
motion and I believe it's very timely
that this should be considered by the
council now and I believe we should
debate it this evening or though I don't
think it needs an awful lot of debate
because I think we are very very
sympathetic empathetic to what you're
proposing thank you thank you very much
councillor they've had faith and I
believe that's really a proposer for a
debate of this motion can I have a
seconder for that abate councillor Ashby
thank you very much indeed as only
council can adopt this motion it will
fall if not debated and as we therefore
are about to debate we can take that
forward can I have a show of hands for
those in favor of do and that seems
unanimous thank you very much indeed can
I ask who would like to lead the debate
here cast lagana thank you I'm pleased
to be making my first contribution to a
debate in the chamber as one of three
newly elected green councillors second
to this motion calling on farik district
council to declare a client climate
emergency this is undoubtedly the
biggest issue facing the global
community and it is vital that we do all
we can locally as well as put pressure
on the government to act we know that if
we do nothing then it is likely to feel
the adverse effects of climate change
early as sea levels rise millions of
pounds have already been spent on
coastal defences in Ramsgate Margate and
if the sea level rises as predicted then
panic may well become an island again
I've worked with councillor Yates over
the last few weeks to prepare this
motion and I echo everything is
mentioned during this speech these are
all things it's important for us to the
counts
to do but this isn't something that just
the council can deliver we will not
succeed unless we engage with the wider
community of Fanny there are groups
already out there leading the way in the
fight against climate change and
protecting our trees and green spaces
some of whom are here this evening and
which we work in with and learning from
them we also need to be working with
other community and neighborhood groups
and with local businesses to provide the
support and resources they will need to
reduce their co2 emissions
I urge all members to think about the
future generations of planet and to
support this motion thank you very much
councillor Gardner Garner and that's
been very well received do I have any
other speakers councillor Campbell they
are you in good form tonight councillor
Campbell you're about to find out I'm
here just to inform the council that
last night Ramsgate Town Council
actually proposed and adopted a starts
of carbon neutral for our local
authority at Ramsgate now you
we've also supporting Street truthful
Ramsgate by adopting an allotment and
saplings and we'll consider funding to
do actually put that process into effect
and if we want to work with Fanny
district council please contact us thank
you
Thank You councillor Campbell
councillor Roth Thank You [ __ ] I'm
delighted to everyone agree with climate
change and they actually approve it
because some people actually don't
believe the climate change I suggest we
should encourage a resident of Thanet to
do more competent and I think cuz lay it
in mentioned as well also encourage the
allotment holders to have a community
compass in area so those people they
don't have a garden or they don't have a
place to recycle and compost their stuff
they can take it to those area for
example I had many times people
complaining about the tree leaf tree
we said gold dust we're farmers and
allotment holders use it a lot I'm a lot
Munhall that I know how much they are
those kind of things important to the
plants you you grow encourage your
people even if they have a small garden
Yap to have a compost bin also recycling
bin if there is not many recycling bin
in the sea areas if we go down the sea
front we see bin but there is no
recycling bin if we have a recycle bin
will not be much pressure on those bin
they can be books in and bottles we put
in a different spin thank you thank you
cancer off cancer Rafa thank you first
of all I think this is amazing and
wonderful that obviously so many people
already seem to be supporting this
motion just reads what I've noticed got
anyway you may have all noticed
obviously the media attention to climate
change the climate emergency and thanks
in the last but large parts of Greta
Sundberg and David Attenborough who
really promoted climate change
emergencies we now have three part green
councillors on planet District Council
which must show that the care that
people in Fannett take about the climate
is obviously rising to their imagination
as well so we need to now think as
individuals and as members of community
that we can do something to help and
it's up to us as it councillors to set
an example Theresa May announced in June
that the UK would be the first major
economy to set a legally binding target
to end climate emissions by 2050 which
is far too long however in a report this
week the climate change committee said
that the targets already for 2025 and
2030 were likely to be missed by even
bigger margins than last year
targets themselves do not reduce
emissions but they do give us something
to focus on you can't improve anything
by just measuring it a government
spokesman said we know there is more
- do we set out plans in the coming
months to tackle emissions from aviation
heat energy and transport as weather
well as further measured to protect the
environment from extreme weather
including flooding protection and tree
planting all issues which we've come
across lately so that's what we need to
do in TDC and I sincerely hope that all
councilors all councillors will support
this motion which will show that we take
the climate emergency seriously thank
you thank you very much indeed for that
councillor Roper
you are in good company I'd see it
practically ever I threw all councillors
in this chamber in inter with you
councillor Constantine is that okay now
okay so we just wanted to say thank you
very much chair and thank you all
obviously to all the councils that have
spoken so well about this particular
issue and as council Yates said the
science is not up for debate we do not
need to discuss the science of this I
have to say as a Kent County Council I
was very disappointed with Kent County
Council not setting a target for 2030
but setting a target for 2050 I want us
to pass this motion as it is I want us
to set a hard target of a harder target
I mean we must take action and we must
have our eyes sighted on the action
being in place by 2030 stretching
targets often work better and this is
perhaps the most important target we
will ever set or ever debate in this
chamber with when I heard this week that
temperatures and allow Anchorage Alaska
were soaring to 90 degrees I mean this
is just crazy climate change we don't
really need anything else to remind us
of the importance so in terms of 2030
the city for city of Edinburgh set a
target Nottingham Bristol Durham and
Manchester I would
like the chamber to think about the
potency and leverage event and the
enthusiasm that would be released here
by being a trailblazer in Kent I would
like the council to think about the
release of power and Suzy azzam and
cooperation of our community again by
being a trailblazer Inc and I would
really like us to lead the way so let's
please make Thanet green thank you very
much indeed counselor Constance I'm I'm
certain that your fervor is not lost by
every member in this chamber and perhaps
here we can do better than Kent County
Council councillor Whitehead and I would
like to thank everyone who's worked so
collaboratively on this motion and I can
think of many councillors who've done an
outstanding job in terms of making sure
that this issue is debated to its
fullest and considered what seems to be
in such a thorough way and I'd like to
echo something that councillor Yates
said and I think this is a really
exciting time for us to think about our
long-term plans as well as our
short-term plans there are small things
that we can all do that everybody here
can do but there are larger things that
we can do as a council in terms of how
we look forward and I look very look
forward to thinking about how we work in
terms of sustainable housing how we work
in terms of our energy how we work in
terms of our long term projects that
will make all of our residents so much
happier and so much healthier and work
to this towards this overall goal and
it's been an outstanding effort by so
many people and it's such an important
thing and I'm so glad that everybody is
so incredibly supportive
thank you very much councillor Whitehead
councillor Stevens have a contribution
from you yes very briefly following on
from what I've been said by many people
here just to echo how much support there
is for this in the community Cliff send
parish councillors invited a
representative
Kent wildlife trust to talk to them last
week and they arranged a further meeting
for later on this month because they
want to say this kind of initiatives go
forward see what they can do in the
local community so it is it is very
widespread support for this okay thank
you thank you very much counselor
counselor wing Thank You chair I think
this is a it's a we talked about in our
training about not having at them enough
situation and this is very much we need
to be in this together situation and
already there's lots of things going off
in the community that I've noticed I
attended a community meeting last night
where they've requested that the KCC
stop using weedkiller and they've
already rewilding it so the enthusiasm
is out there and that's testament to
having us three here so I think how do
we engage that and how do we how do we
actually enhance or or capture that
energy that's out in the community to do
the simple things that make a massive
difference
thank you very much councillor wing we
have a contribution from the vice-chair
of council councillor right Thank You
chair I just like to say I not many of
you know that I actually chair planning
approaching some parish council and last
year when I took the position we
actually have got the treatment sorry I
have to stand up okay I what one of the
things that I did with my committee we
actually have had a tree policy in place
for just over a year whereby if anybody
takes a tree away they have to replace
it thank you thank you very much indeed
councillor right councillor wet Bay
fir'd Thank You chairman and not for the
first time I got a bit confused with
council eights his motion as I think he
did but I don't believe there's actually
been moved anywhere that we should refer
this back to Council sorry refer this to
cabinet to report back to Council the
actions the council will take to address
the arrangements and I'd like to suggest
that it's added to your motion that we
do just that
and that report comes
so the normal council meeting in
February next year what I would like to
say is that we as a group debated this
at some length and again were unanimous
in support of this you know obviously
over time we'll see what the art the
possible is but you know that the will
is there thanks Jerry
thank you very much councillor Bay
effort well that's good
councillor Yates would you like to wind
up please
sure there was just quick question I've
got for the monitoring office because
the council leader has suggested an
amendment to the motion to add the
report after six months and I was
wondering is that possible because I
heard otherwise that that wasn't
possible that's why I didn't do amend it
myself yeah I can't say it's the
monitoring officer we'll give you some
advice on that point thank you cheering
and obviously gets automatically
reported back to cabinet and I think you
can take into account the fact the offer
by via live easier to report by council
in due course it's not necessary to
amend emotion at that point thank you
very much
councillor Yates would you like you
finish your winding up all yes sir first
of all thank you for all the
contributions here tonight I think it's
been really positive and thank you to
the leader the council for both meeting
with Council Garneau and myself to
discuss this in a very open manner given
the unseasoned be hot weather here
tonight I would recommend we go to the
votes I would ask that this is a
recorded vote given the public passion
on this issue thank you very much indeed
councillor Yates we can move to the
photo I find it very unlikely that
anyone is going to vote against perhaps
it could be just as easily done if we
turn around and ask those in favor of
the motion please by show of hands and
that does look unanimous to me
thank you very much indeed chairman and
thank you very much to everybody in the
public gallery who's shown support to
the chamber for this motion I move on to
agenda item 8b motion unnoticed relation
to the council system of governance I
pull upon the Reverend Stewart Piper
Thank You chairman
clearly I'm hopeful for the same level
of support that we've just received
chairman just for clarification this is
a new council body I just like to say
that we are not torii light as an
independence we are not even you keep
light but we are quite happy to declare
ourselves like green the I have a motion
straightforward motion here before
council and it reads as follows that
council members have a debate this
evening to consider gathering
information that may provide members at
a later date the opportunity to examine
the option of changing our system of
governance from the current cabinet led
system to a committee led system there
are many councils across the UK
including Maidstone Council and
Canterbury City Council who have
successfully adopted the committee
system could I just add to that please
chairman that both those councils have
experienced in the last 12 years or so
both systems of governments and both of
them have returned to the committee
structure one doesn't wish to wish ill
on this body but we could be facing four
years of a main a minority
administration which may last the four
years it may not
which might provide the level of
uncertainty for the people of Senate I
have a feeling and I'm hoping members
will agree by having a brief debate this
evening that we want to avoid that at
all costs usually for a cabinet for a
council to move to a committee system
they would appoint some kind of working
group to go and gather all the
information and come back and report
back to members it can often be a
time-consuming as well as expensive
effort my proposal in brief would that
would be that we have a briefing a
presentation to members either perhaps
from Maidstone Borough Council leader or
from Canterbury City Council leader who
have the experience they will bring us
the information and we follow that up
with a briefing from our own officers to
work out how such a thing might be
contemplated so this evening it's a
simple request can we decide as a
council that we would like to look at
the possibility of moving to a committee
system but this evening we are not
inviting a vote to move to the system
can we look at it gather information so
that perhaps later if members feel it's
appropriate to take a vote on that we
can do thank you thank you very much
indeed councillor Piper is there a
seconder for that motion
I've councillor Roper thank you very
much in accordance with council
procedure rule 3.7 a member of the
controlling political group is entitled
to reply
I call upon in this instance councillor
pew Thank You chair I see no reason why
there shouldn't be a debate on this
issue tonight although I'm not sure if
there's an appetite for one considering
the temperature and the climate
emergency that we've just announced
about and yet and I presume I can take
that as a proposal
can't sorry yes yeah do I have a
seconder councillor Benford can I have a
proposal a seconder for the debate to
proceed tonight because I presume we are
leading to that now that's why we've
said yes I've only kept the counter can
adopt this motion it will fall if not
debated it therefore we'll proceed do
members agree this to debate this or are
we happy just for this to be taken
forward out both I therefore believe we
can take this full keg councillor ever
it would you like to say something you
would would you like to start the debate
then please thank you thank you chair
and I'd like to thank the planet
independent group for their motion which
addresses an issue which was contained
in the labor manifesto and I think it's
an idea which is especially relevant in
the context of what has become a see
really hung counselled however I would
say that the motion as it stands leads
nowhere as he did not propose and
outcomes disgusted although gasta to
apply but has of course elaborated on
the motion in presenting it but the
motion itself would simply not result in
anything so I will be moving an
amendment this amendment calls on
members on all sides to come together
and consider what they want it
recognizes that we do need officer
advice and that there is a formal
process which must be followed to try to
change the council's Constitution but it
asked members to set a clearer direction
first not least because there are many
variants of the committee systems what
we would hug is that a majority of
members can reach some kind of a
consensus to inform the formal stage of
the process rather than simply throw the
torch to officers the objective is to
find a solution that works better for
all groups on the council not just for
one of them and I hope that it would be
more or less in line with what councilor
Piper said even if not
specific in detail so the amendment that
I'm moving is on the on the existing
motion we delete the wording from
members in the first line to option off
so it now reads the council calls upon
the four political groups and the single
non-aligned councillor to work together
to identify preferred options and then
it reverts for changing our system of
governance from the current cabinet lead
system to a committee led system and
then insert and then submit those
options to the Constitution review
working party for consideration and it
finishes as does the original motion
there are many councils across the UK
including Maslin council canopy City
Council who have successfully adopted
the committee system that I think will
give us a basis for discussion tonight
and also to take the metaphor would
collectively so I move that motion Thank
You councillor Everett have you got that
in writing that you can provide us with
thank you very much do you have a
seconder for that amendment thank you
very much as counselor not yet we have
to debate the amendment to the motion
first
so can having had one speaker can I have
any more speakers on the amendment
please
councillor Beaufort yeah I just like to
be absolutely clear what is being moved
here I mean I hope you're not saying
that this motion is committing this
council to move from the current system
that we're committed to looking at
options yeah okay and I'd be happy to go
along with that what I do think though
is that the research that goes into this
should be really far-reaching to make
sure we really do get the best option
because although councillor Piper's
motion does say Maidstone counts from
Canterbury City Council successfully
adopted the committee system they most
successfully introduced a committee
system but if you talk to members of the
council they might not all
agree that the operation of it has been
successful also in his opening address
councillor Piper said that the committee
system would take some of the
uncertainty out of this council I'm not
sure it actually would because you'd
still have a son council wait how does
it hand council passing stuff around the
committee system now those of us that
have had experience of a committee
system in the past will know that it can
be an absolutely torturous process and
only that can be bound to say something
that members may deliberately be doing
in order to thought progress and indeed
dare I say that back in the day and I'm
referring to the distant past now I
don't think it's been beyond the realms
of possibility there may be even
officers use the committee system to
move things around so I think it really
is important that whatever we do is
really researched and we do actually
clearly identify what benefit will be
derived from changing because change for
change say isn't you know it doesn't
make any sense and I'm not just saying
that because we happen to be in control
of a minority account so I mean um
beware as anybody that you know that
could change it at any time but I do
think that you know it's a it's a
fundamental change we've got to make
sure we're doing it right because if we
change you know we won't it won't be
that easy to change our game quickly if
we got it wrong thank you
Thank You councillor David do you have
any other speakers on the amendments
emotion councillor Constantine I did I
did indicate fairly early on actually
chair and I'm I'm quite in favor
actually of a committee style structure
from what I know about a committee cell
structure iris struck this morning at
Kent County Council by the debate that
was taking place from the Kent Youth
Council who were given a presentation
today and they said and I'm paraphrasing
but they said that public confidence in
politicians is at an all-time low and I
think that needs to be heeded they also
said there were 20,000 councilors
dealing with nine years of austerity
when we have too much to do with
little to do it so politics and the role
of a councillor is in a very difficult
place at the moment and we know
councillors are absolutely best placed
to know what really needs to be done
locally working alongside residents so I
would support this a thorough look at a
committee style system because I think
it could introduce more openness and
more transparency for instance we could
coop coop people with relevant
experience onto those committees such as
residents tenants and other service
users I think that could be extremely
helpful and we need to be more I think
we need to be more member led but also
be seen to be more member led and this
will allow us I think better to
represent our our residents I think it
would give a slightly more agency so I
think a committee style system it's
possibly an imperative to opening up our
local democracy and really letting
people access what goes on in the
chamber and influence it and see what
the work we do Thank You councillor
Constantine do we have any other
speakers on the amendment no we do you'd
like to speak on the main camp counselor
Bailey please thank you thank you yes I
mean I agree with what most people have
said here the original amendment and the
amended amendment the only thing I would
add to sorry counselor Everett's
amendment is that you just did the
binary choice between committee and
cabinet whereas there are other councils
I have hybrid systems as well so I would
just add maybe that in to explore I mean
I know we are just exploring at the
moment I mean I think the part the
public perception is that there is too
much power in too few hands in a cabinet
system and every counselor here was
elected to represent their people you
know their constituents and I don't feel
as if that is actually happening with
this system there may be of obviously it
needs exploring and there may be flaws
within the
my system as well but yeah we won't know
until we explore them so yeah I just
think there's definite benefits in
investigating every system and if we do
have someone come to speak from another
counsel I know Tunbridge Wells have got
a good hybrids or a hybrid system so
maybe we could have speakers from a
variety of different systems models
thank you Thank You councillor Baily
Casper Piper would you like to sum up on
the amendment it's advice I've received
from the monetary officer Thank You
German I'm happy with the amendment as
presented by councillor ever and as
discussed by members thank you thank you
very much councillor Piper a week an SS
any more speakers we can proceed to a
vote those in favor of the amendment
please raise your hand
thank you very much and those against so
once again that's unanimous
thank you very much indeed that motion
will be carried forward
my apologies I'm a bit new to this we
should now debate the motion as amended
could I have a speaker who'd like to do
such well I've now had the advice to
take it to the vote but I think we've
actually done that what you've done so
far is you've an amended the original
proposal that now becomes the
substantive motion what you haven't done
is now agreed that substantive motion if
I've never proposed in a seconder for
that that'd be helpful thank you thank
you very much we have councillor Piper
and counselor counselor Denis returns
like I had my iron councillor Denis now
can we have a vote in favor of the
amended motion please the substantive
motion and that looks unanimous again
and those against I don't think I need
abstentions in view of that thank you
very much indeed
thank you very much for that on your
patience counselor Piper you have your
hand in the air when I went to school
chairman the teacher always said if you
need to go to the toilet put your hands
up in the air chairman I'm old I need to
go to the toilet from time to time more
frequently than others
may I please beg a three-minute or a
five-minute pause in Proceedings for a
comfort break can stir by pipe I've been
reliably assured that you can just go if
you like can I have your microphone off
there we don't hear anything
[Laughter]
moving on to agenda item 9 we have
counselors from right across Senate to
hear the leaders report this evening are
you in good form counselor Beauford I'm
not sure my not forgotten about so
getting ready to go home not as much as
everybody else will be having to sit and
listen to it but there we are
Thank You chair a new automatic number
plate recognition by NPR parking system
is now live at trinity square car park
in Margate following a successful launch
this ticketless parking pilot allows
people to pay for parking by cash or
card at the end of their stay so they
only pay for the time they've used the
car park this is something we know is
welcomed over the past few weeks
officers have spent time on-site
supporting car park users with the
changes particularly blue badge holders
and residents using the Medical Center
there are also signs letting people know
there is a ten minute waiting period
that is free and we will continue to
monitor the car park usage here and
carry out a review to evaluate the
impacts and benefits this new kind of
parking might bring satanic parking
provision and its costs are perennial
issues and if successful digital parking
may provide some of the answers members
will be aware that cabinet is to
consider a proposal to sell the freehold
of the dreamland site to their see and
operator saying
heritage limited it's only right that we
look at the next steps needed in order
to a successful long-term future for
dreamland and at the same time protect
the council from the risks and
liabilities that are inherent with
maintaining the status quo it's fair to
say that options for the site are
considerably more limited under
continued council ownership and might
mean that iconic parts of the site
remain vacant and unused for many years
to come
clearly we will need to ensure that
conditions are attached to any sale to
protect listed heritage structures and
to restrict the future use of the site
to leisure I would like to remind
members that for this council to CP o
the site was a bold decision there's a
neighborhood the transition of dream
Lane from being a sad derelict burnt-out
wasteland to becoming the bustling
visitor attraction it is today returning
it to the private sector who are
committed to further investment in the
site is a logical next step and I
welcome the opportunity to review this
in more detail at a cabinet meeting in
August this month saw the introduction
of finance surgeries members of the
public have been invited into the
council offices to go through the
councillors accounts for 2018-19 each
year the council opens up its books for
inspection but this time around in a bid
to be more accessible and transparent
the finance team has been holding
sessions out of hours to give more
people with the chance to engage in this
process the feedback from those who have
attended has been positive walk in local
people through the finer detail of our
accounts has been a really valuable
experience and demonstrates our
commitment to increase transparency with
our residents I'm delighted that the
successful bid of a four hundred and
ninety seven thousand pounds for the
funding from MH CLG will mean a
significant new resource can be provided
in Ramsgate to help address the issue of
rough sleepers the new somewhere safe to
stay rough sleeping center will be a
place where vulnerable people currently
sleeping on the streets can access
professional help and guidance including
an immediate shelter and mental health
support the bid was coordinated by TDC
in partnership with the charity pathways
to independence and will make a real
difference
to support in rough sleepers in a
district in June a better Cliftonville
hosted adultery square day which
involved bird box painting shrub
planting a litter pick and refreshments
and a new pluck to honor the dog we
Square townscape heritage initiative was
also unveiled the thi initiative funded
by the national literary heritage fund
and the council is aimed at celebrating
the rich and varied history of dog wear
in its gardens and the Dobby squared I
was also a chance to thank the many
volunteers were put in so much hard work
supporting this scheme and promoting
community involvement and pride in our
area the council is working with the
Friends of Ellington Park on a project
to regenerate the park funded by a
successful 1.8 million
national lottery heritage fund grant
this will see a new community cafe
toilets restored bandstand and landscape
works in the park in June
volunteers from the community and the
council took part in a spring clear out
day with two van loads of waste and
recycling cleared making way for a new
digital archive happen over the next two
years the team behind the project will
be calling out for historic material
relating to the park and will create an
online catalog and website images from
this archive will be used to create
heritage and ecology trials around the
park
we received a significant number of
complaints and major attention regarding
the hedge maintenance work carried out
at the Windsor gardens on the 4th of
June although Kent police have confirmed
that they found no evidence of any
disturbance or damage to nesting birds
and therefore concluded that no offenses
have been committed under the Wildlife
and Countryside Act 1981 we are keen to
improve the processes followed in
relation to this work in the future and
we're currently considering the
following actions I do apologize because
this is a bit repetition of what
councillor Ashby said earlier but I
think it's worth repeating although it's
not a statutory requirement we're
recruiting an ARB or a cultural officer
as soon as possible
ecological risk assessments are to be
carried out for a variety of parks and
open spaces works which include the use
of new technology we have purchase
there's a Tron this stage of
thermal-imaging wildlife camera and this
will be used alongside traditional
methods of ecological monitoring as part
of the prescribed process before works
are carried out check sheets will be
included as part of the ecological risk
assessment to ensure compliance is
documented recommended recommendations
have been sought on this from the RSPB
wildlife trust and other local
authorities which will help us shape
this new parks and open spaces service
standards will be drafted approved and
published from the councils website so
the public know exactly what to expect
from us a review of our arrangements
with contractors including exploring a
new permit to work process for any
contractors carrying out work on our
behalf the opening of the Turner Prize
2019 exhibition is now just three months
away and we're pleased to be working in
partnership with the gallery and other
local partners as preparations begin to
ramp up the news that actor Russell
Tovey will curate Margate now an Arts
Festival which will run alongside the
first two weeks of the exhibition it
generated even more public interest in
what is shaping up to be a really
exciting programme between September and
December we expect to welcome over
250,000 extra visitors than it which
will be a much welcomed boost to our
tourism economy Thanet has increased its
number of award-winning beaches by 40%
going from 10 in 2018 to 14 in 2019
this means that 14 of finest beaches
have been named amongst the country's
very best and it means they're a blue
flag beach along every 2.7 miles of our
coastline all of our blue flag beaches
were also successful in their bid for a
seaside award and as a result the planet
now has 21 Beach Awards more than any
other District Council in the country
we're immensely proud to achieve so many
prestigious awards for our beaches this
is recognition of all the hard work
putting in by our officers various
agencies voluntary groups and local
people to protect our beaches and ensure
they remain world-class the high
standard of our beaches is obviously a
major factor in attracting record
numbers of visitors which put tremendous
pressure on our cleansing
trying to cope with the vast amounts of
litter generated we will continue in our
efforts to educate the public to dispose
of their rubbish responsibly or better
still take it home with them now
apologized to leaders that in my report
I did include a section on East Kent
housing but it is firstly same as the
bit I read out in my earlier question I
think you can do without that but if you
want to ask questions or make comments
on it please fill through thank you
thank you very much councillor Beaufort
I call upon councillor Everett
should he wish to make any comment or
ask earlier questions I think I can find
something to say to here I'd like to
thank the leader for the advance copies
report slightly inaccurate as it was as
he says but so for reasons which are
understandable and I'd like to welcome
the positive developments described for
the districts including the additional
blue flags for our beaches and the work
being done in Ellington Park which i
think is a really good example of local
community engagement it's right of
course that the leader should focus on
good news but I believe that we also
have to confront difficult truths and I
have to say that why I've heard this
evening about his can housing doesn't
really do that the situation with gas
safety certificates is concerning
because it puts our tenants of risk
it is important of itself but it is also
a symptom of a more fundamental problem
which I suggest is the gross failure of
governance and management within East
Kent Housing ekx was set up under the
current leader in 2011 it was according
to a newspaper report at the time the
71st arms-length management organization
set up in Britain to manage local
authority housing it was however the
first to do so on the basis of sharing
responsibility for more than one local
authority area it was also unusual in
its principal raison d'être was to cut
costs initially by sharing management
the labor group at the time councillor
Byford may remember opposed the move a
significant factor in that were concerns
about governance and that nobody in this
authority could be held accountable if
things went wrong this council is
responsible in law but ek H is health
and safety failures but which cabin
member or senior officer is willing to
put their hand up and say that they
personally let the council's tenants
down over gas safety council housing
affects a minority of residents but to
those who are our tenants is probably
the most important relationship that
they have with this council and they
include some of our most vulnerable
residents the risk of the Alamo
structure is that it pushes there having
concerns to the periphery of members
attention especially if they don't have
a significant number of council homes in
their wards and so receive little or no
casework related to each age
nevertheless the structure has had eight
years to prove its worth if we turn to
mr. Willis she's former report to
cabinet on the gas side Certificate
debacle we learned that the East Kenda
can't audit partnership was consequently
asked to look at electrical
certification lifts fire safety and
Legionella safety and that initially
findings are revealing that there are
failings in these areas too we're also
told that there have been concerns about
performance aspects of eki classic
management since the Almo was
established and in particular concerns
about procurement and contract
management predominantly in connection
with failures to follow proper
procurement processes and that a number
of contracts have been poorly managed
our officers were initially misled by e
KH about a number of gas safety
certificates outstanding eki failed to
supply a health safety report cure at
the end of April citing issues with bank
holidays which were obviously unexpected
or for me a second promise deadline to
do so in my and there is a continuing
dispute with the former contractor PNR
about overpayments which runs almost 1
million pounds across the four councils
by any measure the e KH mission
statement trusted by our residents the
council's and our staff to deliver a
great and reliable service rings rather
hollow meanwhile what was TDC doing we
can see that an improvement plan was put
in place by the four count was earlier
this year but what was T DC's
contribution to governance and how we
got to this point I would urge all
members to visit the east count
East Kent Housing website which purports
to disclose the organization's
decision-making processes the last
meeting of its board for which there is
any information provided was on July the
16th 2018 council a game attended as a
new board member representing TDC
further board meetings were scheduled
for September the 24th of December the
10th but if they did take place and I'm
told that they did you would struggle to
learn about them from the e KH website
as for the Fannett area balled
appointments to which around our own
agenda Senoia this council will never
put forward anyone that's all in 2018
and as far as you can tell from the ehh
website he never met either
similarly there are no quarterly
performance statistics online for later
than December 2018 there are no
decisions made listed and there is no
food plan provided so perhaps the EAH
website it's just another example of a
failing of the organization but either
way it's government the structure
appears to be more no more than a
Potemkin village concealing the fact
that elective members from the for all
authorities have not actually been
scrutinizing its senior management at
all and certainly if they have been and
they don't seem to have done a very good
job I don't want to leave the impression
there's no Briony KH working hard for
residents although I think now you don't
mind uncountable but time and effort
into trying to remedy the organization's
failures cabinet will consider the
future of eco checks meeting on July the
25th due process notwithstanding I hope
the leader will confirm that as far as
Fanny is concerned it doesn't have one
thank you very much for that ever your
fervor is no to councillor Everett it
should be mentioned however there have
fortunately not been any unfortunate
incidents councillor David would you
like to respond yeah Thank You chairman
I mean cash forever it's right this was
set up in in 2011 very shortly before I
ceased to be leader in 2011 and it's
probably worth pointing out that the
governance of 8ih really starts
discounts was concerned sat with his
party
and you kit for seven of the intervening
years you know I think that this evening
I've been totally open about the
shortcomings of ek8 we recognize that
something has to be done about it think
it's bright and proper that in the short
term EK h are supported to actually
bring the situations as far as
regulation is back to normality and as
you've already alluded to there's paper
coming to cover knit and 25th i think
where there are some option in there for
the future of BK h and i'm sure you'll
have something to say on that night as
indeed will i thank you thank you very
much indeed counselor Bofur
I call upon counselor Reverend Stewart
Piper to comment or ask questions I can
assure you didn't miss too much care sir
I thought he saved the best bit German
about the blue flag beaches for after I
come back I think he's right Thank You
Linda for the report we had it in plenty
of time to have a look at it there's
lots of good things in here for me one
thing stands out above the others not
saying it's any more important but for
me it stood out and that is this the
evidence that the council is listening
has listened and is now communicating
with members of the public as well as
members of this chamber much better I
genuinely believe than my first four
years here show me where really we
didn't seem to be doing it we are
communicating we're telling people what
we're doing we're not hiding the
failures it's it's quite here it's quite
clear here East Kent Housing have had
major difficulties personally I'm very
pleased with the response that we've had
in the monitoring officers report
already shows it's being taken very
seriously and please permit me just to
say three years ago when the councillor
first brought this kind of thing to the
attention of this council the response
was very very different this is very
encouraging and I thank the council for
it and thank you for Europe
thank you very much indeed councillor
Piper that's a very positive and
contribution because a look at our
council as well councillor Beaufort do
you have anything to add at all thank
you very much
councillor Roper would you like to ask
any comment make any questions asked me
yes I just will be very brief because I
think we all want to go home fairly soon
first of all I'd like to echo canceller
Piper's comments in that I welcome the
report there's lots of lovely positive
things in here and it does show that at
last the public are being listened to
and being consulted with that long may
that continue that's been shown
particularly with the the hedges fiasco
so we should call it that but the only
one main comment that I would like to
add is that please please can we do
something about the toilets okay thank
you very much thank you very much
councillor Roper Castro papered nothing
to add
could you switch your microphone off
forecast Roper thank you we on to agenda
item 10 we have a report of the Chairman
from the chairman of the overview and
scrutiny panel are you selling good form
councillor Campbell well we'll see we'll
see
Thank You chair yes the committee had
bet we've had our first meeting of the
committee will be determining the work
programme for the next few months
this is contained in the written agenda
I won't repeat it there for everyone to
read we also decided to start a
committee a scrutiny review working
group to scrutinize the traveler
situation in the district as we
mentioned earlier on and were subject to
a particular question from councillor
Tyler there is a meeting in a couple of
weeks time if you contact Democratic
services you wish to contribute to that
I'm sure you'd be most welcome basically
I would just like to like to welcome
count all the new vice chair whomever
that may be in the next agenda item and
thank the the sake Charles hungry for
his support and assistance in the
scrutiny committee thank you question
our welcome thank you very much indeed
councillor Campbell are there any
questions or comments for councillor
Campbell from the chamber I don't think
there are councillor Campbell thank you
very much indeed the next agenda item is
actually not about the vice-chairman of
scrutiny it's represented gender item 11
representation on outside bodies were
councillors please refer to the notes on
their chairs I call upon the leader yes
thank you chairman I would like to move
the the two lists one one that appears
in the agenda and one that appears on
the members notes so the first one is
for executive appointments now that I'm
just proposing that we keep the bodies
there but no proposals for membership
will be made tonight that will happen a
cabinet meeting at a later date as far
as a representation the non-executive
ones you'll see on your list but those
organizations where we have volunteers
to sit on those bodies and I would
propose that those appointments are
agreed by council tonight and that the
remaining bodies that currently don't
have any representation that I invite
members to contact democratic services
if they would like to volunteer I
understand that not everybody understood
that they could put their names forward
so if you're interested in any of those
bodies please would you put your names
forward as an aside chair if I may I'm
also asking that democratic services
actually contact the organisations that
we've got on these lists to find out
whether in fact they still do want
representation from this council because
it has to be said that in the
councillors are busy they haven't always
got time to go on these other bodies but
I do understand that there may be some
organizations have as part of the
Constitution that need to have a member
from this council we should be aware of
that so so many chair thank you very
much Casa de Beauford I'm looking for a
second of a councillor Everett you've
indicated that sure I want to make
movement to add councillor Pauline
Ference as account
was representative of m'appelle cotton
Museum and quicks house I think we can
clear include that can I take that
forward then to approval by members
agreed thank you moving on to agenda
item 12 changes to committees panels and
boards nomination of members to serve on
committees group leaders may wish to
take this opportunity to advise a
changes to their nominations to
committees panels and boards for the
remainder of 2019 2020 council paper do
you wish to advise of any nominee
nomination changes I don't care man I
would like to propose the removal of you
from overview and scrutiny as well as
the vice chairman your services are no
longer required and I'd like to nominate
that you be replaced by councillors
Parsons and Coleman cook Thank You
councillor Beauford I'm really quite put
out by that but notwithstanding I'm sure
that can be taken forward councillor
Everett have you got any amendments at
all I do chair we would like to add to
our list of substitutes for the plane
can we see councillor Liz green
councillor Pat Moore and councillor Alan
curry
thank you very much councillor Everett
Kansas your Piper do you have any
amendments no changes chairman thinking
thank you very much councillor Roper do
you have any changes no changes thank
you very much thank you very much indeed
we now move to the election of the vice
chairman to the overview and scrutiny
panel is there a nomination please
councillor Beauford Thank You chair I'd
like to nominate councillor parsons
thank you thank you very much guys with
a foot is there another nomination
seconding that councillor Campbell thank
you very much indeed that clearly meets
with approval from the chairman are
there any other nominations I think we
can safely take that as carried thank
you very much indeed
halation councillor parsons an item
agenda item 13 changes to the
constitution the senior officer
employment rules I call upon the
monetary officer to introduce thank you
chairman and members will be aware that
this report and the recommendations
therein have been the subject of
discussion at the Constitution Review
Working Party which then recommend them
onto the standards committee they'll
then further considered by the standards
committee and down now recommended to
the council by that body however a
particular issues have risen the last 24
hours
a detailed legal matter concerning that
report and I don't think it's
appropriate for me to try and explain
that detailed legal matter at this venue
and it was right and environment for
that to happen
therefore what I'm proposing is that we
draw this report and I resubmitted to
the Constitution real working party for
further detail consideration thank you
very much
are we happy to take that forward
councillors thank you very much moving
on to agenda item 14 the paid policy
statement I call again on the monetary
officer Thank You chairman yes the pay
policy statement is merely a statement a
listed policies and processes we have in
relation to pay it related to races if
you mean highest-paid and lowest paid
you're not being asked to approve the
core documents in this you merely asked
to approve the policy statement as a
reflection of your existing core
policies the main changes from last year
about issue about changing and some of
the end
deputy chief officers names change
there's a change in some minor
typographical errors and also I think
there's a reference to the new
consultation on the potential pay limit
on 95 thousand pound for severance
payments so I propose as counsel for
adoption
thank you very much our Chairman I move
that the recommendation is set out in
the report be adopted
with the vice chairman please second a
second that mr. chairman two members
agree thank you
agenda item 15 members allowances the
report back from the ex job
committee members are asked to note the
report are we happy to do so members I'm
sure we are that concludes the business
for this meeting of the council I would
like to say thank you very much to
everyone here for bearing with me this
was my first meeting I did my best I
hope to do better in the future thank
you very much indeed